welcome everybody welcome to West area
plumbing my name is Mark Cargill I'm
chairing the meeting this evening right
just a few items first is housekeeping
no far larger schedule this evening so
if you do hear a fire alarm please
follow the members out of the room
because they will be in the lead and
meet in the carpark
by the side of the the pub the window
please write please note this is a
planning planning meeting with public
participation not a public meeting
therefore only persons registered to
speak will be allowed to do so the
meeting is being webcast so if you do
not wish to be shown then please make an
officer aware of us at the appropriate
time for our speakers this evening some
tips on the microphones don't get too
close to the actual microphone itself
otherwise it becomes very distorted but
just speak clearly into it and it will
be alright right the sequence of events
for the evening is as follows I will
introduce the item supported by the case
officer who will offer a description
town encourage their parish counselors
are allowed to speak for up to three
minutes members of the public objecting
will be allowed to speak for up to three
minutes and the applicant will be
allowed to speak for a commercial time
either three or six minutes I will give
a 30-second warning for time up ward
members then will be allowed to speak
for up to five minutes at all stages the
members of the committee are allowed to
ask questions of any of our speakers
right after that we moved to technical
questions of the officer that have been
raised during the proceedings and then
into debate and the vote all this is
detailed in the agenda could I please
ask everyone to turn their phone still
either off or to silent for the duration
of their meeting please thank you right
now then before we start the meeting
you'll see there is an update sheet on
the seats around you there is quite a
bit of information this time I'm going
to pause for five six minutes
but people just have a review of this
place and I would also bring to
attention of the item 17 - oh three 206
artful watery college that again on the
second sheet there is an update there
especially from WCC highways which you
may want to have a look at as well so
I'll just pause for a few minutes while
people have a have a look through that
thank you right carry on with the
meeting now right I'm Victoria Chowdhury
senior planner David Jeffrey senior
planner David moonship planning officer
Amy flew its planning officer thank you
for everyone all right
I'll start the meeting apologies for
absence Thank You councillor dueling
declarations of interest members there
any attack Eurasia scatter bonds I
should be speaking on the third item in
support okay thank you
right minutes of meeting members do you
have any comments on the minutes that
have been presented if not are you happy
for me to sign them after the waiting
thank you very much okay them right then
we can move on to our first item of the
evening first item is 18 / 0 0 4 4 life
/ 4 which is the recreation ground
carpark and it is Victoria is presenting
Thank You chairman three-year temp
reconsent assualt for the installation
and operation of an observation wheel
with ancillary facilities to be located
on the council owned recreation ground
car park access from swans nest lane as
indicated by the black dots shown here
apologies is that better oh sorry I'll
stop okay thank you
I'll speak louder sorry I do apologize
the application site is outlined in red
on this slide and shown in the context
of the surrounding area the proposal is
for the observation will to be in place
for a continuous period of six months
between the months of March and
September each year within the proposed
three-year temporary period
additionally five days either side of
the operation period it is so there is
five days sortie the side of the
operation period to install and
dismantle the wheel this is an aerial
image of the site with the site
indicated as outlined in yellow noted on
this image are some of the buildings
that have been mentioned in the offices
report for information this is a view of
the recreation ground looking towards
the proposed application site the
application site is substantially the
same as that of the previous will prove
last year and that was in place for
summer last year this is an aerial image
of the site with the footprint of the
proposed observation will impose onto it
the number one that you can see on the
site denotes the the location of the
proposed ticket office which is enclosed
on a proposed platform number two shows
the location of the proposed generator
and number three shows the location of a
proposed welfare block for those
attendants on the site the dark blue
line that you can see indicates the
location of a of a screen to screen off
the proposed generator and the welfare
block and the light blue line that
surrounds the site is the proposed
location of a boundary fence curb to the
compound of the site the proposed rule
will be a total of forty meters in
height
included in the platform on which it
would be mounted
the world would comprise of a total of
30 gondolas and have a maximum capacity
of 180 riders this slide provides images
of the proposed ticket office generator
and welfare block this slide gives an
indication of the proposed scream that
would scream the generator and the
welfare block and the proposed fence to
the surrounding of the compound this is
an image of the wheel when it was in
location in Birmingham and shows the
platform on which there the wheel stands
the platform has level access with a
ramp leading up and the green arrows
show how riders would gain access to the
wheel this is a Google image of the
previous rule that was in sight as as
viewed from across the Bancroft Gardens
this is a Google image taken from Bridge
Street it should be noted that the will
proposed under this application would be
five meters higher than the wheel
depicted in this picture this is a
closer up image of the wheel it should
be noted that the proposed will would be
similarly orientated to that shown in
this picture albeit that this was the
previous wheel and this is a longer
distance view of the previous bill that
was in location and given a longer range
view of that will in relation to
historic asset of the Royal Shakespeare
Theatre German there are up to updates
which would be made in the update sheet
and the recommendation is to grant
temporary approval thank you Thank You
Victoria
our first speakers this evening are
Elizabeth Dixon mr. Nick birch yes you
have three minutes between you
have you decided how you want to split
the three minutes yeah I'm going to try
and do mine in just over a minute thank
you I'll give you a 30 seconds okay so
I'm Elizabeth Dixon from accessible
Stratford and oh I want you to say that
I don't think this application is as
inclusive as it could be which is why
I'm here this evening I did ask some
questions of the case officer to try and
help me make my decision and they
weren't answered so and earlier before
I've come into the meeting I've actually
spoken to the applicant who's tried to
solve some of it for me but I'm still
going to go ahead with what I want you
to hear I'm disappointed that you didn't
get my information until the update
sheet although it was submitted in time
so you've only had a short time to
consider what I've said which I don't
think he's long enough so I'll start now
and I recently spoke at the overview and
scrutiny meeting because I didn't want
the same mistakes to happen this year
that happened last year and last year
after it started several changes were
made but it was only ever assisted
access it was never full access which I
could explain but I won't at this time
for different abilities this wheel for
access should have a mix of ramps and
steps that should never just be a ramp
to get on to anything because that
doesn't suit some users 30 seconds
please you've shown a red carpet type
thing but it's aluminium in the plans
and aluminium is not good for walking on
it gets slippy so it's not a good
surface I asked about the gradient don't
know what the gradient is never been
told gradients are important it's got 30
gondolas for 180 people and only what
the applicant says a mobility impaired
one for mobility impaired don't know
what that means
case officers said wheelchairs the
applicant didn't I'm assuming they mean
wheelchairs but one out of 180 isn't
good enough okay thank you for that
right I do know that there have been
some we were talking about some of the
issues that you raised and I'll raise
those are technical questions for the
officer at the appropriate time but yeah
I'm pretty sure we think members do have
any questions you like to raise so I
think you said that the ramps obviously
are important but also steps is
important could you expand on that for
me well in part 10 building regs that
it's ramps and steps it's never just one
or the other and of course there aren't
any guidelines for something like this
so we're just sort of playing with what
we've got and trying to do the best so I
would expect a really long low slow
gradient possibly more than one in 20
because if you're a wobbly Walker that
means somebody sticks they can't walk on
ramps it doesn't work and that's why I'm
saying ramps and steps that's what
that's why I said that there are a lot
of precedents for this type of big-wheel
including the one the eye in London
facilities are all made for that I don't
I've never used it but I understand that
the one in London which is nothing like
this so it's probably not fair to make I
don't know if it's fair to make a
comparison but the one in London you can
put wheelchairs on till all the gondolas
because they're different sizes and so
you say there's lots of presidents there
aren't because there aren't that many
wheels across the country really so it's
hard to make an equal judgement I would
suggest I think treat each one is its
own healthy on
did anybody advise you of difficulty
last year with the will that we had - no
this is a different size up yeah there
were several people couldn't use it so
we changed the entrance round to it last
year and they changed all the ramps but
it was still it was only a Cystic I mean
I don't know I can't think of the
planning officer was now but they came
out we looked at it we agreed at the end
and it was said again in the overview
and scrutiny meeting that it was only
ever assisted
since last year so that's why long low
slow ramps handrails help you know some
handrails thank you thank you very much
okay all right oh did you want to race
it who asked the question was if we do
approve the you would like those
conditions put on if you could make some
changes to it I don't want to stop it
I just would like to see it improve to
make it inclusive at the moment I don't
believe it is I know what the note what
the case office has said and you know as
I said I'd ask some questions beforehand
and perhaps I need to even have been
here but if you could just make some
tweaks from my point of view then that's
fine because we but you know one out of
100 one person out of 180 isn't very
equal in 2003 okay thank you very much
thank you okay our next speaker then is
mr. Nick Burch
like you think you have two minutes
thank you
good evening the observation wheel does
not contribute towards the town's
world-famous status or enhance its
cultural offer it is a monstrosity a
tacky pastiche and makes a mockery of
other genuine heritage assets the core
strategy requires this game to have
demonstrable community benefits but the
committee reports and the applicants
planning statements only contain
unsubstantiated conjecture where are the
comments from any local businesses or
strap forward or from Shakespeare's
England supporting its confirming that
it will enhance tourism improve the
business environment or provide more
jobs there are none the committee report
admits that they were never to be some
harm sir character in appearance of the
conservation area but I considered the
temporary nature of this proposal is
material the harm a temporary but gets
cumulative even worse the longer the
wheel is here with every person who sees
it if the wheel on the rack is to be
removed every winter blank motion should
be required every year before it is
reinstalled again there are fewer
objections to the proposal of this year
because the public believe that they're
valid comments were ignored last time
and as permission was granted last year
and the council gained revenue from it
that you will grant permission anyway
prove them wrong this proposal
contravenes key policies in your own
core strategy you may on this basis
difference decide to refuse application
finally I referred to your committee
report for last year's application
I consider that there are exceptional
circumstances to justify the granting
that we heard your seconds place for you
to grant permission for three years the
circumstances must now be very very very
exceptional I ask you they are not I
finished thinking but these last
questions of course think it it's not a
Johnson I understand your point about
the evidence about business impact but
just anecdotally for example in my own
experience visiting the wheel that then
encourages people to use some of the
business alongside that that side of the
river and make a trip there that they
might not otherwise have made do you
accept that there's been some
of benefit in that respect I operate the
boathouse which is one of the closest
businesses to the wheel which has an
overbearing effect on where how we
undertake our business the the view of
it
we can't make any discernable answer to
that question we don't feel that we've
had any more traffic it's a balance of
things some people I'm sure may be drawn
across the bridge by the wheel but so
we're in a competition for people's time
and money so if people are coming across
the bridge with half an hour to an hour
to spend they we've now got an added
attraction on our side of the river for
them to go on rather than go to the cafe
or take a boat out so it's in
competition for us so on balance
although I can't give you any hard
evidence and my feelings are that it's
in competition with us an established
business we've only been there for a
hundred and sixty years thank you thank
you very much indeed thank you all right
our next speakers Elizabeth also Emily
dental is my cousin
again three minutes in your own time
Thank You chair I'm gonna try not to
speak for three minutes that'll probably
make you happy I did just want to say
that I'm trying to get into the modern
world of technology and there is a
Stratford updates webpage which last
time I looked at there were 526 happy
faces and only 85 angry faces regarding
the prospect of the wheel returning to
Stratford so a massive proportion of
people using that webpage or in support
of the wheel coming back to town and
we're only going to talk about at the
moment is access but could you put the
image back off of when the wheel was
invert past one great thanks I think the
really important thing to note is this
is not the same operator as last year
dancer attractions operate in a very
different way to last year's operator
the entrance and the access through the
wheel is different to last year's it's
also important to note that the contract
that's been signed with the council a
requirement in there is to meet the duty
under the Equality Act to meet make
reasonable adjustments for access so
it's part of the contract with the
councillors landowner that they do this
they're well aware dance attractions
that if they don't have access through
there's no point having the adapted
gondola that they have because people
can't get to it so there is access from
beginning to end so where you look there
there's a ramp it's red carpet shown
here but it won't be red in Stratford
there's a ramp up the gates wide enough
through that entrance barrier for
wheelchairs so people can get through
access the ticket office which I think
was a problem last year and then what
happens is that the adapted gondola will
be the middle one so whilst they can
load five gondolas at any time the
middle one is a level access with a ramp
you can put a wheelchair in so that
gondola and up to three other people
there so the floor of the gondolas have
steps you do need steps to those four
but the middle when it's level access
it's level access when you come out
again I think it's important as well to
note that dancer attractions are saying
we we did have to get the application in
quickly so the contract was awarded in
February we maybe could have been clear
some points about access when we talked
about staff assistance I think that was
misinterpreted is that people had to be
manhandled onto the wheel that isn't
what we meant it just means that anyone
needing that adapted gondola will be
directed towards that middle access
point and they're only assisted if they
need it if they need some help it's also
a reference to her dancer attractions
operated in Birmingham a lot of Sen
children came to the wheel there from
the local schools the staff with this
company are trained to watch out for
children who maybe don't like the crowds
are getting distressed they can guide
them around to an access at the bathroom
if we find it quieter there so it's it's
in the ethos of the company that there
will be accessed through the site they
were awarded a disability access from
Disability Resource Center and they were
also inspected and found suitable by the
City Council's access officer last year
Elizabeth Dixon and Emily have been in
conversation before this meeting in the
reception I'm hoping that all the access
matters can be resolved if you got any
questions were happy to answer them
thank you
are you Lizzie or two seconds over so
better the next time
and I've got a couple of questions
before cancer balance jumps in Elizabeth
did raise a few items and I'll just like
you to John clarify those the ramp this
one in twenty gradient has been
mentioned so the the fact that is a more
gradual slope than that okay thank you
and the early mininum camp she was
alluding to the fact that that could be
difficult for access or if it's wet ice
assume or some other we've never known
an issue with this anywhere else
it's brand new aluminium it's not of an
English type it's of a German type which
has a petroleum lip which then the
wheelchairs
with on it we've never done issue in
Birmingham have been any slippage ease
on it but we would monitor it and I'd be
more than happy to work with Elizabeth
if this gets granted and invite us to
come down and show her through how we
look oh that'd be excellent I'm sure and
so the only other one was that there's
only one gondola that has this
accessibility is that normal or
acceptable
I think this did say something but you
can just explain a bit more no sorry
actually it's exceptional when the use
of gondolas are produced there is no
accessibility car produced with them the
first song we operated this woman
Birmingham asalaam has been noted that
there was no accessibility people had to
be physically assisted in and out the
car and that was if they could if they
could come out of the wheelchair we
quite frankly didn't find that
acceptable we paid for all the design
and development of a car to be
manufactured to have all accessibility
we if you ask the accountant is it feels
it was it financially viable no but we
fell to the company that we wish to
provide that for our guests all guests
get assistance no matter how much they
need more or less all our guests get
assistance some guests will need more
assistance we just provide that as a
matter of course okay thank you
customers I think you've asked my
question that the point really was you
can address what the first speakers
concerns yes I certainly can and I can
fully understand where they're coming
from to be quite honestly a counselor
but I would like to reassure everybody
presence that accessibility comes from a
very personal side of the family and
it's important to us causa Fielding what
concerns me is cueing if there is if it
is popular how you going to queue how
much control where you give to queueing
people
this is classic problem within it
sorry this photograph was taken at the
Birmingham Christmas Frankfurt markets
if anybody's attended the Frankfurt
market I don't know at least it's
incredibly busy we at no time
experienced any cues past our front
steps which would be the red area there
at any time are the gondolas CT
seating only or are they standing
seating and going to getting off the
gondolas what sort of assistance are you
giving doesn't look like this a lot of
room from that image around the back I
don't quite understand the question
sorry but you've got to get on and I'd
you get all how to get off this chair
you get off the other side no there's
two exit points if you look to the
photograph
so you entrance the front side of the
gondola and you exit off the back side
of the gondola if you can just see the
small piece of red to the bottom right
that's where they exit through they go
through that white tunnel there are two
exit points on either side looks like
it's stepped because you come out is
that correct or is it just the way the
image step did you go in or as you come
out no no no that's wrong that's wrong
are you looking right at the end of the
red arrow it's a gate as a handrail
there's a handrail on the gates a
handrail there it's a handrail there yes
I can't see that thank you and just a
very minor part I'm sure it is in your
report on page 2 it discusses lighting
and it says upward lighting I was I'm
assuming that it would be downward
lighting so it doesn't smell not like
pollution it's only focused on the wheel
is but he focuses on the wheel it
doesn't protrude out from the wheel
right members any other questions
councilman Johnson so the surface so it
will be metallic looking surface it's
not going to look like that so that's
carpeted but this will be metallic
okay in terms of it's obviously been
raised about whether one gondola is
sufficient is that gondola that's loaded
all the time with people who are
able-bodied or not in a wheelchair or is
it reserved for people that need extra
care we tend to reserved it so that when
they come along in the queue that they
take the precedence on that seat right
okay yes there was an issue about
handrails because obviously the access
point isn't just about people for
example who are wheelchair access is
maybe people who walk but have
difficulty walking do you feel because
that's obviously quite an open stretch
to get it there is there is there
sufficient support for safe somebody who
needs handrail access there are some
handrails there the slope that was the
smaller
past that is very very shallow it's more
like a flat walk up there but we assess
each site when it's in stitching and if
we feel we've done rounds and we have
extra rails to put in if we if we need
if we think it's necessary right so that
is something that can be added yes
can I ask if the committee were minded
to grant it I know you said you were
happy to meet with the same as Dixon
after it's constructed but would you be
willing to meet with her maybe before
it's constructed to disco you know in
light of the plans to discuss anything
that could be done in advance of the
constructions always good yeah I think
that's
wait come back you're saying was anyone
gondola available for the disabled how
long does it take to search for the
wheel to come round to pick them up you
can alter it
it's totally pre-programmed so you know
the speeded up all you
well you can what you would normally do
you would load five the five cars that
will come to the bottom yeah and then
they all access Conda would be the sixth
one so if you have somebody there that's
waited to use that how many gondolas
have you've gotten in the in on the
wheel thirty say this five gondolas will
arrive mm-hmm and one of those will be
for disabled person yes so the next five
that comes through one of those will be
available for a disabled person no they
gotta wait for the Pacer yes yes so but
they waited nine the same as everybody
else listen Clement whether they're not
gonna be very happy
well everybody else waits so thank you
very much okay thank you very much right
tell me any technical questions you'd
like to ask members no thank you no
thank you let me say you technical
questions no location I'll open it to
debate category two knobs an observation
on the fact that this type of apparatus
goes round at grade one two or three
buildings throughout the country so it's
not as if it's a rarity the Stratford
castle and I think it was quite
successful last year were the people
that supported it there was certainly a
number of met people that are opposed to
it but if he brings people into this
village village I call it but it's not
well it wasn't in 1962 when they was
talked about in a wheel so as far as I'm
concerned on collaborative proposed the
the the proposal with the conditions
that soup the first person that spoke
which new appears have been talked about
and moved forward
at this meeting I think I think like I
said on this application last year it's
a difficult one I think there are lots
of pros and cons I can see that for some
people the visual impact is significant
I don't think we could get away and I
think the strongest difficulty with it
is the visual impact and for people who
don't like the look of it it's not
something they can avoid it's there all
the time for that six months and it's an
important site it's right in the center
of our important tourist heritage so I
see that definitely in the side of the
cons I also felt last year I did feel
that the bottom of the site was slightly
cluttered it I don't feel it was it
wasn't difficult to navigate but it did
add to a cluttered feel on the other
side of it I actually don't feel that
the long distance views it can be seen
for a long way away so if you're coming
down from Henley and Arden you can see
the top of that wheel and we've seen
from some of those photos you can see
edges through the trees to me I don't
think the long distance views are hugely
problematic I think it's if you're on on
the riverbank it's it's very significant
I am and I have always been when I
looked at it last year one of these
people who once I saw it in sit you
it doesn't hugely offend me but I'm very
conscious of the opinion of people that
it does offend and I take that seriously
on the I think I respect people have to
say local businesses but a little
respect for the boathouse as a business
and I understand what they say about
competition but clearly that isn't a
planning consideration and I appreciate
I'm not I don't think that's what mr.
Burch was trying to say I don't think
that was his planning reason for it not
being there but it isn't a consideration
and actually I do take the opposite view
on I'm very keen that planning committee
members shouldn't make decisions on the
basis of anecdote or even you know huge
weight on their own personal experience
but I do know that visitors that I had
to Stratford we made a special trip to
the riverbank to go on it we as
Saltz went and spent money in local
eateries that we wouldn't have otherwise
spent so I don't you know there clearly
isn't any evidence about the precise
economic benefits but I'm not convinced
by the argument that it detracts
economically and it takes people away
from spending in other areas I don't
think that's what happens I think if you
attractions in places it encourages
people to make visits that they wouldn't
have otherwise repeat visits that they
wouldn't have otherwise made so I think
the access point is really important and
if I think I think where I am is that I
think on balance I think for me I'm in
favor of it and I think I can only I can
only speak from a personal opinion that
the visual is the strongest negative and
for me it doesn't offend me
I am conscious that I think it's a good
point made by the agent that people on
the webpage have been in favor and I
have to say that is my general
perception of this is that there are
some people who strongly dislike it but
actually I've had quite a lot of sense
that most people think it's acceptable
and they don't mind it at all and have
been quite happy with it I haven't had
an inbox full of emails you know saying
that this is absolutely horrendous you
know I think unbalanced wants has been
people can people have accepted it so I
think for me as I say for me it's a very
fine balancing exercise it was last time
it continues to be and the main reason
for me it's such a fine balancing
exercises because of the strongly held
views by some people and I I'm never a
big fan of imposing things on planning
grounds on people who really don't like
them but I think for me and the fine
balance like tip in favor of this wheel
because I think it does bring benefit to
the town in terms of our tourists the
diverse tourists offering which has to
be diverse and my only caveat would be
that I know what miss Tonto says about
being willing to work with miss Dixon
and I would welcome a note being placed
that perhaps there is a meeting in
advance of any construction to look at
practical improvements that can be made
but I think overall from what I've heard
from miss dancer I feel satisfied that
there is a deep willingness on the part
of the applicant to make sure that this
is
accessible offering to people with
different types of accessibility issues
thank you yes we can't ask for note in
that particular item Antonius council
carriage with that note I will second
the proposal I would just like to
clarify councillor Barnes you mentioned
with the certain conditions are there
any other conditions that you are
looking at well from what I can gather
the that this leader believed to be more
conditions to to make sure that the
disabled can get there
it may be accessible at the moment but
there was some concern and and handrails
and slope which is under 20 or whatever
do need I think to be put in the
condition so what no what we were
suggesting which is what counter John's
suggested was that we asked for a note
that the sorry it was a mini dontoh and
Elizabeth Dixon meet before construction
so those things can be ironed out are
you happy with that well I would prepare
a condition on to say that they were our
dad just not a note that accessible to
all
okay the only thing is so if it's a
condition you want they need to have to
be a condition otherwise it's a note to
say that this thing has to happen oh
okay then thank you cattle did you want
to comment yeah Thank You chairman yeah
I think I'm probably not going to be
successful here but they're just looking
at this new application I mean the the
thing in favor of it as opposed to last
year is it does appear to me that there
is better ticketing and there is a
better amenity and I would agree that if
this committee is minded to grant this
that we should do whatever we can within
reasonable means to ensure it has some
access however chairman that that said
and and members III as I did last year I
I don't find that this particular
activity it is suitable for Stratford on
I even there's travel maven is a
particularly but important visitor
attraction this to my mind is completely
inappropriate and there are grounds
members to refuse this application and I
would say that they would certainly that
this attraction is in an area of
restraint and and it also in my view
goes against our core strategy in that
it is it provides unacceptable part of
the character and appearance of a
conservation area and those would be
valid grounds to to refuse this
application I am not convinced that its
its presence adds much to the the
general economic well-being of Stratford
I don't think it does anything to to to
bring people into Stratford from outside
it might be a novelty for strap for
donee ins but I would not be in favor of
granting consent and I would go against
the officers recommendation for the two
planning reasons I've mentioned thank
you well we do have a proposer and we do
have a seconder for for the item the
proposer proposal is to grant plan
permission with the note that we've
agreed that
a meeting between the developer their
name Emily down to installation there's
a bit that didn't take place to address
any accessibility issues members all
those in favor seven chairman against
the committee therefore resolves to
grant plane permission to seventy 1804
for 9/4 thank you right the next item on
the agenda is works of college and this
is 17/3 206 and David is our presenting
officer when as Elizabeth vacates the
chair
over to you David Thank You chair thank
you everyone can I hang on there please
thank you Thank You chair and as you
correctly state this is application 1703
206 ful this is a hybrid planning
application which includes full planning
details for the erection of a 64 bed
care home and also three blocks of extra
care assisted living accommodation and
also outline proposals for the
commercial of arden house - an assisted
living unit and community facilities for
the residents of the development the
application site sits to the south of
Henle and Arden and is currently the
site of the Henry and Arden College run
by work shoe college group the site is
shown in this slide
members will note the original building
on the site which is odd and house the
grade 2 listed building the large
teaching annex which is attached to that
building and which has those dots on it
air access is provided to the sight off
the a3 400 Stratford Road and the
nearest property is Hearst house also a
grade 2 listed building there are
further properties to the west on the
same access tract and there are tpo
trees the access Junction and a public
right-of-way which crosses the site and
continues east to west members may
recall that the site already benefits
from an outline permission for a Kerr
village which would have provided a
smaller care home and a greater number
of additional housing for over 55 this
slide shows the indicative layout which
was considered along with that scheme
it's notable that that permission
remains extant usefully on this slide
the red line boundary there show
the position of the large 20th century
teaching and X which is attached to
Arden house this is the scheme we're
looking at today means the application
proposals there's a large care home
located to the rear of the site and
three blocks of assistant assisted
living units are located west of Arden
house overlooking existing sports
pitches in terms of the sports pitches
officers understand that they would
remain available and owned and operated
by the college and they are outside of
the redline boundary of this application
this landscaping plan shows the
development in further detail a lay-by
is proposed at the access to enhance
maneuvering in and around the entrance
and parking is provided in areas of
existing hard standing on the site to
the east of the proposed Kerr building
significant soft landscaping is proposed
around the areas of parking and existing
tree cover at the access Junction and to
the front of Arden house is to be
retained in terms of the appearance of
the proposals these images are taken
from the applicant design and access
statement they show in the top left-hand
corner a line-drawing elevation the
southern elevation of Arden House and in
the bottom right corner a sample
elevation from the proposed assisted
living blocks which would be alongside
Arden House designed as villas the
intention here being to reflect the
Regency style of Arden housed in a
modern idiom the materials proposed and
a pale bricks to reflect the color of
Arden house this slide shows the entire
southern frontage elevations of Arden
house along with the existing
and proposed assisted living units
moving from east to west the first
assisted living unit comes into view as
you can see these are graded on
different levels so it's a terraced
effect the second unit and the third
unit the designs have worked to ensure
that the new unit so intended to be
respectful of the height and massing of
Arden house and they don't exceed its
roofline the care home to the rear
they've shown on this slide in plant
form and elevation it selects a less
complex design than the pillars sitting
to the rear of the site it's I need to
be less obtrusive amendment to the
scheme have identified a need for
further landscaping in that elevation
there and they have managed to change
that to provide those unscathed this
visualization shows views of the
development across the southern frontage
of Arden House it demonstrates the
extent of tree cover and this
visualization shows the reverse view
across the southern elevation with Arden
house at the far end members should note
that there have been some modest
elevational alterations since these
images were prepared particularly to the
dormers to make them more vertical and
slightly less square this aerial view
shows the care home to the rear and the
South moving on to some idiot images of
the site this image shows the site
access looking from the north this image
shows the view from the south that the
access and this image shows a view into
the access as per the outline approval
for the Kerr village
the same access is access point is
proposed to be used but will be
remodeled to enhance pedestrian safety
and ease and discussions with the
Highway Authority regarding the
potential for a keep clear marking at
this Junction have been noted in the
update sheet and could be secured
through a section to 7/8 agreement this
is a view of Arden house showing the
listed building and glimpsed through the
trees to the left the listed building is
the red brick teaching annex with a
glass atrium a view across the southern
elevation members note the large cedar
of Lebanon in the grounds heavy tree
cover this views from the rear of Arden
house and shows the entrance to the
teaching in X another glass atrium there
and parking areas to the front then this
view shows the rear of the teaching in X
and the rear of the college grounds in
general tennis court referred to in the
committee report looking in the
southerly direction and then rotating to
look in a more easterly direction
towards the College and the teaching and
X that's the southern elevation of the
teaching an X notable here is the change
in levels and teaching in X being a
three-story building and sunken into the
ground chair that concludes the
presentation there are a number of
updates in the update sheets which
you've invited members of the public to
read these include the response from the
highway authority indicating no
objection and legal advice regarding the
appropriateness of the section 106
request which was received from the NHS
trust this concludes the request is not
SIL compliant accordingly officers have
amended the recommendation and the
recommendation
reflects the consultation period which
expires on this application today as
such the recommendation is to grant as
per the update sheet details thank you
thank you our first speaker is
councillor Broadbent or council
Tomlinson as substitute okay council
Broadbent thank you have three minutes
in your own time just press a button at
the bottom ability that's it thank you
got it that's it thank you good evening
thank you right though deserts and Henry
J pcs support the application in
principle as per our report on the
website however the access road to the
site from the junction with the a3 $400
has not been adequately addressed the
width of the access road along its
hundred meter length is a major concern
a major safety concern not only for the
equipment's and site users but also for
all we thought the users of the a3 400
trunk route there is no alternative
route south if a major incident occurs
on the m-40 south which has happened
many many times we are not traffic
engineers however we have attempted to
take a practical approach and take it on
board the comments of our parishioners
you live on the site we have users
restaurant reference the development
control advice note 15 regular access
standards as published by the DLA this
is a narrow rural road on a 7 degree
incline from the junction with the with
a major trunk road width of the opinion
that the visibility surprised at 2.4
meters and 4.5 meters from the highway
edge are inadequate being at both
distances inhabit inhibited by the
contour of the ground mature trees and
scrub we note in the document that the
distances traffic volumes and speeds do
not synchronize with the situation on
the ground
we suggest that
taking the minimum requirements a more
practical approach on the developers
should be taken and we would recommend a
speed survey taken at the 30 mile per
hour sign or that the minimum stopping
distance of 50 meters south of the
junction be carried out to prove this
fact we suggest that the radius of the
south corners be improved the banks
reduced to 250 millimeter in the vision
supply area and the scrub and a limited
number of trees be removed even if
they've got tpo
safeties prime importance in our
instance what appears to be play very
immediately on the corner it is known is
just a hard area at least and no other
nowhere other than the grass sward on
the I three four hundred the the lack
there is a lack of passing prices all
LIBOR facility on the narrow hundred
meter length and he will affect the I
three four hundred we have got photo
gusts unfortunately the photographs we
sent to David Jeffries have not been
published because we were a bit late I
apologize for that but if you have
gotten them now actually with you it is
essential that the safety of all users
at the a3 400 and the site access remote
control in consideration of the design
irrespective of the loss of some mature
trees or the cost of the project
any questions
had you taken that picture yesterday at
five o'clock the traffic would have gone
way up to the entrance to the sports
ground hey Kevin did you have a question
and just for my reference then you're
talking the visibility's plays yes are
you talking about the trees that we can
just see there to the line yeah behind
where that sign is okay and the bank and
what are you what you're saying that the
visibility's disabilities players that
have been accepted by WCC highways are
not sufficient you think absolutely okay
thank you all right any other questions
members well thank you very much the
lead counsel right our next speaker is
Warren Harding
mr. Harding you have three minutes in
your own time while I support the
overall you redevelopment of the college
I've got to object to the plan so the
gas they currently stand due to the
access to the site from the Stratford
Road up the unadopted single track Lane
and the safety of the existing site
using the same access I've studied the
various reports from the Highways Agency
and the traffic volumes etc which are
tailored to suit the application two
examples of this being firstly the
highways being happy with it there's a 6
meter splay onto the Stratford Road but
in reality this narrows to less than
three three and a half meters within two
car lengths of the main road but the
Highways Agency taint no view on the
other
unadopted lane as it's not their
responsibility basically if three cars
enter the site at the same time and one
is trying to come down the narrow lane
you're relying on courtesy for for who
is going to take priority
but if three cars backup then one of
them's backed up on the Stratford Road
one dimensional plans that are used to
show a clear line of sight both north
and south winix exiting on the Stratford
Road but don't show this severe gradient
out of the lane onto the Stratford Road
or the mature hedgerows trees and
embankment that brought the views to the
south nor did they take into
consideration the fact that when traffic
queues back from the lights in peaked
there is nil visibility to the north
again first hunt experience that there
is repercussions of these are the if
turning right during peak times you have
to edge ad into the northbound traffic
and hope that anyone traveling south
will let you in whilst if turning left
during normal traffic due to the
restricted viewing northbound traffic
often have to brake to slow down as they
cannot be seen before vehicle commits to
making the turn onto the main road I
would also like to advise of two
instances that happened in the recent
poor weather both being the result of
the gradient of the access point firstly
on attempting to join the Stratford Road
on the evening of the 1st of February
around 7:00 p.m. I was braking at less
than 5 miles an hour and could not stop
my vehicle at the junction I slid onto
the Stratford Road fortunately there was
no northbound traffic and her accident
occurred and then the following morning
my plumber phoned me from the Stratford
Road advising me that he could not get
up the his vehicle up the entry slope
onto the lane so he left it in the
access play and walked up the lane being
unadopted is not treated by the council
and as such it's the same at any time
that there are icy or snowy conditions
just multiply that scenario button by
numerous more vehicles and imagine the
consequences the applicant has a traffic
survey based on the historic traffic on
the site when it was used as a college
this takes into account of constituted
vehicles that arrived between 9 a.m. and
9:30 and let the seconds please they
left the site between 3 and 4 p.m. so
off-peak times no problems but the same
as arriving at 11 o'clock at night or 4
o'clock in the morning during peak times
they will not accommodate the fraction
of that traffic I feel that the council
will have to give them full due
diligence the safety aspect of this
development should make a personal visit
to the site at a peak time a former
report themselves as to the safety of
these assets and to prevent any
potential liability issues should then
accident occur in the future thank you
very much ma'am is there any questions
you'd like to ask I take it that you
look up the lane
I do yeah and I'm actually as you see
the drawing up there just off the
left-hand side of the screen
we go we have to it's a quarter mile
along that lane and it is exceptionally
narrow the applicant has put a couple of
labels in which was that my to his
drawing so I'm very appreciative of what
the attempts he's made I'm sure that
with traffic passing there will be
head-on situations where I've had
situations in the past where I've just
got in my car and I said well if you're
not moving nor am i I'm going home
you're stuck obviously it's an unadopted
road it does lead to conflict and the
more traffic on there the more conflict
there will be so okay thank you can
securely does that really go to the
cul-de-sac of the railway line or does
it go on beyond there it goes but I
guess over the railway line and onto my
property
okay well thank you very much indeed
all right our next speaker is guy
Wakefield the agent mr. Wakefield you
have six minutes in your own time
good evening members thank you the
opportunity to speak commendation to
this application which seeks to
redevelop a previously developed site on
the edge of a settlement which is
heavily constrained by the Greenbelt
this application has been the subject of
detailed discussions with your officers
and also with the parish council here
tonight it's some three years on from
the previous application submission that
permission when it was supported by
committee members in July 2016 was
prepared by the college without any
involvement from a specialist in
providing elderly accommodation the site
was eventually put on the market by the
college but there was no interest in the
approve scheme involving as you've heard
a care home and units for the old 55s
retirement units be over 55 it's worth
noting that between 25% of 50% of care
homes with permission never get built
out such as the specific expertise
required to design and plan these types
of developments as the Parish Council
was generally aware there were a lot of
bids made for the site for elderly and
non elderly accommodation as well as
other uses the college eventually chose
octopus healthcare as their development
partner giving their experience in
providing elderly accommodation and
because of the view that such a form of
accommodation was still sought by the
local people both the applicant and the
parish council who worked hard together
to address as many issues as possible we
fully appreciate the outstanding concern
raised by the Parish Council involving
access the proposed access onto the a3
400 has been discussed at links with the
highway Authority however the aware of
the parish council is concerned that
proposed access Arrangements take into
consideration the operational needs of
this particular scheme which is slightly
different from the previous consent like
the applicant's own highway consultant
as with the extent planning permission
the highway authority conclude that the
forest access is appropriate it is
perhaps also worth mentioning that Pozzo
will generate less traffic including at
peak times than the previous use by the
college in respect of the update sees we
would accept
the keep clear markings if members felt
that this was necessary the package of
benefits that this offer this steam
office is as follows a viable and
productive reuse of previously developed
site in the location heavily constrained
by the Greenbelt the reuse of a vacant
grey - listed building the removal of a
very large unsympathetic building on the
site an unsympathetic extension to grade
2 listed building the provision of
much-needed elderly accommodation in the
form of a new care home and extra care
units for example analysis shows that to
be an unmet need for 269 market standard
care home beds within the market
catchment area which could increase the
791 by 2033 the provision of the extra
care units will allow people to downsize
from the existing family homes and free
up those properties for other people
wanting to buy the provision of what we
generally believe will be an attractive
place for people to live while providing
added choice and competition in the
marketplace 7 the creation of
approximately 74 and part-time jobs plus
construction jobs the sale of the site
number 8 from the college - octopus
Healthcare will provide monies to pay
for improvements of new and existing
facilities by the college to provide
enhanced education that ends the package
of benefits thank you very much for
listening and we hope you support the
officers recommendation thank you thank
you right quatre jours Catalan the
Heritage Council heritage officer feels
that the block to the north is very
harmful to the to the listed building in
front and it dominates essentially so
she he or she had any weather it's
usually he the it the blocks to the west
are deemed as being acceptable but that
block to the north is and what what have
you been able to do to address that
concern because it is a concern for me
okay we have made some changes to the
design of the care home
to try and make it more acceptable to
the heritage officer who I think on
balance concludes that there is less
than essential harm paragraph 1 3 4 vm v
PF etc etc I think hey it's a two-story
building rather than two and a half
three stories that dress that just needs
to be cleared up I think as far as the
the actual design and scale and mass and
building is concerned that is somewhat
generated by the need for a 64-bit care
home the reason why the previous consent
wasn't effectively attractive to the
marketplace is because it was for a 16
bed care home the model generally used
by care home providers is for a 64 bed
care home and that is required because
of effectively the resources need to be
poured into the operation of the care
for example staffing levels and various
other things that go with that so I
appreciate that it is a big building it
was felt that it was better to be placed
in that location behind our house which
is arguably the least sensitive
elevation relevant to our town sources
primary frontages that to the south or
the east effectively but that that is
where we felt was the best place for for
that particular building to go and we we
feel that the relationship between two
bit that it is a two-story building and
the way that it's designed in terms of
its its shape and form is generally
considered to be acceptable I appreciate
it diamond design issue you may be of a
different view was any consideration to
moving it further west I mean there's a
lot of land here and actually whether
you you know I don't know there's quite
a lot of space and I think the concern
of the cons the heritage office is it
that by being directly behind it
dominates and essentially Auden house
becomes lost yeah I think to make
everything work between the buildings
I've the the car parking and the space
around the buildings I think we did look
at it and I think David may have a
comment on that as well but ultimately
we generally felt that it couldn't be
moved any further west than it currently
is proposed because because of the need
to provide car parking around the
living units and the car parking
arrangements etc adjacent to the care
home as well it just it it wasn't felt
that it could be moved any further west
for those reasons got Lawton Thank You
chairman good evening and like my my
questions really relate to the to the
access I know the site very well
personally because my son used to go to
this college when it was operated and as
has been pointed out by members of the
public at peak hours it was very
difficult and it relied an awful lot on
the the largesse of drivers to allow
people in and out in my car which was
particularly wide I was constantly on
the verge to let other people out you
don't appear to have done anything to
improve what was a poor situation and my
question is you know you're spending a
lot of money on a very impressive care
home but you're not spending anything on
the access so it seems to me like you
you're spoiling the ship for a high
pathar it is a reason why you can't
improve that access it is the highways
officers say that they want a pedestrian
crossing point but it doesn't appear
from what I can see to be any pedestrian
access only on the access road you're
going to be walking up the road if you
are a pedestrian am i writing that or is
there a full pedestrian access proposed
when you say walking up the road you
mean the internal access road off the no
from the a 3 for 4 from the Fe for 4 to
get into the the body of the site yeah
is there a pavement proposed yeah I
don't if David would take you through
that I could have a sender technically
it's got control off yeah do you have
the detailed drawing showing the
pedestrian access
so sorry the well the procession through
that the blue line there is your over to
your ownership to me that suggests like
that access road isn't in your ownership
am I wrong the the actual internal
access road is not owned outright by the
college I believe it's in multiple
ownership which is why we would I think
we have a right to maintain it but in
terms of doing anything more fundamental
and significant to I think we we would
struggle in that respect we can of
course widen it by putting in the past
in Bay's that has shown indicative ly on
that plan but I don't I don't know what
you're thinking in terms of maybe where
the consideration is you've given to
what in the whole thing really almost
yeah up some small bays in but whether
you have the ownership and the ability
to be able to wire them the whole thing
because evidently that's that to me is
the key issue that to the public is the
key issue
yeah try and speak for the parish
council but I believe that their
principal concern is the actual turning
into a nail to the site there is a still
concern in terms of the nature of the
access road in the width of the access
road but I believe the gentleman that
spoke before me clarified that by the
provision of those passing bays
themselves on the own on the internal
access road that that is potentially
deemed suitable and addressing that
particular issue references gentlemen
would you just like to comment on that
we would like to see that too okay thank
you I think I think just one thing to
add to that I believe that there are TPO
trees along that section of the road and
continue on to the a3 400 clearly in
terms of the access Arrangements the
applicant has taken pre-application
advice and highway authority
notwithstanding the advice from their
own highway consultants who have deemed
that to be acceptable obviously is a
difference of opinion with the parish
council and the the the the other object
on on access Arrangements on the council
well yes my question was somewhat
hijacked by councillor Richards but
there are no problems I think as I'm
getting about what my question was is
that a pedestrian access there is a
payment I can see that but the road is
not going to be widened but you did
mention that you're putting in some
passing places which yes you can see
pointing out the parts in places
actually and then as you can see you can
see these just the one no it would be
longer than that so it would essentially
allow for I think two vehicles to pass
behind one another before you actually
then turn into as you can see of the the
left-hand side there as you turn into
the accent actual hot car parking area
and obviously the the pedestrian is the
improvement of the pavement and
therefore the highway works in the top
right hand corner there that would then
lead through the trees and then onto the
foot way through there okay I'm with you
summarise on this particular issue we've
obviously taken advice from Highway
Authority we've we've done as they've
they've advised we've taken into account
the previous permission as well and what
was requested by the council as part of
that permission and the second thing is
that we've tried to retain as many of
those trees those TPO trees as possible
if there is a strong feeling that those
TPO trees
to go in order to provide the safe
access to spite the Highway Authority of
saying we would consider that that the
advice from our own and from the highway
authorities that it's not cancer
carriage lovely thank you first thing is
there any affordable element to this
no there isn't it's all c2 accommodation
there's no c3 accommodation being
proposed on this ok enough are you
developing this or managing this I mean
is this are you going to build this and
then straightaway run it as a care home
and an extra care facility Oh octopus
health care will either will either
build it out and then use one of their
management partners to manage it in the
future or they will effectively sell it
off to another so nothing's in place at
the moment
nothing's in place at the moment ok ok
fine thank you
apologies for that
that's the fielding just going back onto
the junction being so narrow at the
present moment if there's emergency
vehicles are we going to have problems
well again the advisers and the Highway
Authority and our highway consumption is
that it won't be problems I mean the
actual intensive intensity of use on the
access road itself is really going to be
from the assisted living units if
anything the care home will obviously be
active
occupied by people who will not be able
to drive vehicle other the members of
staff the assisted living units will be
occupied by people of an average of
about 68 to 70 years old some of those
people and some of those residents will
still have access to a car some of those
who drive we don't expect high
percentage of those trips to be at peak
hour times the difference between this
scheme and the previous scheme is that
the previous scheme was a c3 development
for over 55 s where the average resident
would have been somewhere in the region
of about 63 to 65 and the general advice
is that those types of people would be
more likely to drive the vehicles than
with an extra care scheme said if
anything on balance this scheme probably
probably generate less traffic than with
the previous consent I'm just concerned
about about the road leading to the
buildings to the jump the second
gentleman who spoke if we're going to
have the heavy traffic coming off there
and traffic coming off and going to the
farm buildings beyond are there going to
be farm track tract traffic going along
that road I'm not sure they can answer
that and before we move off the roads
the highway element Richard you just
like to comment on on that place I'm
just going to break the protocol
slightly I just want to pick up on a
point that that clearly is important to
members in the local community and that
is how we look at the access to this
site one thing I would ask members to
bear in mind is obviously the lawful use
of the site as an education
establishment and the patterns of
traffic that that can generate and the
bottom of page 39 in the agenda you'll
see how the highway votives assess that
and they've concluded that there would
actually be a reduction in traffic as a
result of this proposal which would be a
betterment to the highway safety so
that's one thing to bear in mind the
other thing to bear in mind is of course
the passing Bay that you've just seen
and the addition of a footpath which
again our betterments of the scheme over
and above the existing situation I think
in and regards the query about widening
it and the TP OS that would be we'd have
to go back to square one members will
need to consider the proposal that's in
front of them tonight officers haven't
assessed it on the basis of the loss of
TP owes and obviously at first glance
that that would be a concern if it is
necessary to lose TPS or whatever reason
so that would need a further assessment
thank you okay any other questions
thank you very much counselor say well
thank you chairman and good evening
members I know that from my original
comments made in December 2017 but some
progress has been made on this
application as you're aware Arden house
is a listed building and his such is the
key focal point for this site and I do
have a concern that the villas and
indeed the care home will still swap in
size and mass over this particular mr.
building and it was her question are
there too many villas my main concern is
the junction of the a3 400 and the side
entrance in his guise as a colleague the
traffic would be happier during turn
times and obviously quieter during
college recesses I would emphasize that
not all students arrive by their own car
but use buses and trains therefore I am
still of the belief that traffic will be
greater and consistent throughout the
year than was previously this will cause
an issue with traffic turning into the
site from Henley which if delayed will
cause tailbacks
toward the traffic lights there will
also be a similar issue for traffic
give me turning right on today three
four hundred towards Trafford I know
from the update sheet that these of keep
clear road markings could be used this
would be a step in the right direction
and that my answer if you are minded to
approve this application that you would
you ensure that it is secured and our
section two thousand eight I spend some
time talking AmeriCorps D access
from this site but you also happens to
be concerned as if we're the ceiling of
the joint eyes Council
I know chairman this is a hybrid
application which also covers access and
therefore I would ask the committee that
as a ward member if you do approve this
hybrid situation I'm included in any
final discussions on such issues as
access I do still have a concern on
whether are enough passing points on the
access road to last until a traffic
finally chairman I can say one good
thing it was good to see that the war
memorial commemorating the lives of the
old boys of this school as it used to be
before a college that previously
occupied that site are to be retained in
enhanced memorial garden thank you Thank
You councillor any questions councillor
haven't gone you say you'll represent I
can't elaborate on that whereas I can
understand that might have taken care of
any flooding issues but my tab will you
decide the runoff quante three four
hundred can cause issues there I like
you spread right over to the houses
which are on the eastern side to a three
four hundred and indeed there have been
problems during the past Celtic Eric you
mentioned consultation on transport
matters if this is recommended to grant
and the only ones I can think of are the
key
anything else you wanted to sort of be
involved in I am concerned about that on
that particular Road it needs me more of
a two-way traffic if possible it has to
be like that
I do see more traffic going through you
will have more business commercial
vehicles going to do them which came
through in the past and therefore if we
can actually solve that problem of that
part of the road the private road then
will help to ease all the rest of the
problems okay thank you very car sir
okay members opened for technical
questions thank you in terms of the
design of this site is this is the
footprint of that building to the north
is that largely stayed the same
throughout the when the application was
originally made and three offices
discussion the footprint has remained
the same what has altered slightly is
the position of the building and
landscaping in this elevation you
referred to before the Heritage
Consultants comments around views of
Arden House and its respective dominance
on the site and part of the applicants
response to that as well as accepting
the Heritage Consultants view that there
was a necessity of a condition that
secured the ongoing use of Arden House
was to slightly alter the position and
include landscaping on this elevation to
ensure that that's a softened view if
you think kawasaki eriko salons yeah on
Greenbelt issues it's mentioned in the
report 30 to page 32 that a previously
demolished building was somewhere around
whether
two on the far west of the side I does
one do you take previously demolished
buildings into account I didn't think
you did if it's not there it's not there
as far as I'm concerned yes we do take
them into account and where they where
the land is demonstrably brownfield that
makes a difference to our assessment in
terms of Greenbelt policy also it
wouldn't necessarily take a it wouldn't
be taken into account as far as openness
goes bland field I can I can certainly
appreciate yes there's you're correct
there's two steps to the green belt
assessment we have to consider whether
good good to clarify that the other
thing was there's something in here
about sill and it not being required
I've lost it in the report but I seem to
remember that because one building was
being demolished that there wouldn't be
any sill to pay because I don't know why
because the floor space created here
seems considerably more than that that's
being demolished so the extra care
living units under ordinary
circumstances would be sellable but
there is an exemption where there are
demolitions to occur on-site and newly
created sill liable floor space is
offset effectively against floor space
which has been demolished and in this
case the red brick teaching annex that
you've seen in the photos has a lot of
floor space will be demolished so what
you're saying is that the red brick
teaching annex which has been demolished
has more floor space than the the three
new buildings yes thank you councillor
bars Lancaster riches as you can see
everybody is very concerned about the
road
we're a district council we don't have
any authority on the road the County
Council seems to think it's alright
can we put any conditions or can we do
anything about the concerns that appear
to be there with the board members of
parish council everybody that's there
because I feel that if we don't do
something I'm not the person to ask it's
really ask David and Richard as you may
expect officers have had ongoing
discussions with the highway authority
in respect of the access lane and
movement onto the road three four
hundred those are partly reflected in
the update sheet where the comments of
the highway officer in relation to the
proposition of a yellow box junction
were that he did not feel that that was
justified he felt that keep clear
markings could be appropriate and that
they could be secured through two seven
eight agreement as my colleague Richard
said during the meeting our approach to
the assessment of this Lane has been in
the context of the existing lawful use
of this site which does bring with it a
permitted development effectively which
can create a lot of highway traffic it's
also in the context of the granted
outline permission which did include
access we have to balance so we we can't
really do the application before members
you can control the development through
the recommended conditions on the update
sheet that would be us officers
recommendations Katherine Catalan yes
you're a slide David I'll wait
you had a slide that showed the entrance
looking straight at the entrance did you
bring that up please
that was impressive um that house on the
right that's that's presumably a private
house there's obviously a lot of cars
parts out there is there a danger that
those coming are coming into the road
and are we in a position to be able to
put yellow lines up that or not clearly
already got a tight road I'm concerned
that that's going to make it worse
yeah I understand that's a private road
it's not being a recommended requirement
of Highway Authority the similar problem
applies to the main road people parking
on that path to visit that house is it
just one house or is it - all right how
many seven several that I know I've
driven up there and there's been cars
parked along that we can see one there
already that's kind of materially impact
the visibility we if we have the ability
to insist on double yellows being put to
a certain distance either side of the
entrance I think that would be at least
to be a step in the right direction
both frankly Council Norton Thank You
chairman it goes really back to a follow
on from councillor Barnes this question
David is again my only concern here is
the entrance we've got three comments
from WCC highways on the page sheet
which I'm sure we can condition I'm
vague about this box Junction I take
councilor thorough wells point and local
points that I know this bits textured
Road very well so if you are coming
south from hand Leonarda n-- if there is
two times a day a key that goes past the
the leisure center and obviously cars
wanting to turn right into the site
without a box junction it's going to
back traffic up into henley which is bad
at the moment I'm not sure what WCCO
saying here a box function could be put
in or they don't think it's worth it
because I think if we can condition in
this is my question can we condition
that a box junction is included in terms
of that scenario that you described
where you've got the queuing traffic
obviously at the moment there's a chance
to dry the night think oh there's an
access there I'll pull back and leave a
space they won't always do that
what County have suggested is not a box
junction but a key clear sign such that
anyone in that queue would see it and in
theory would leave a gap for someone to
go in that that's the solution that
they've decided is acceptable obviously
it's up to you to decide whether you
agree with them that that's an
acceptable solution it officers view it
is but the answer is we could condition
it
they County put it forward actually as
to be covered by section 278 agreement
which means be done at a later stage but
yes you could condition it would
effectively thank you that's fine
second question chairman if I make the
WCC highways requirements seem to be
pretty much a de minimis they're not
asking for a lot here now I will accept
that if there are tpo trees here what
have a you know there is an issue but it
doesn't look to me that the splay
they're certainly on the left-hand side
or that bell mouth junction could be
widened considerably without damaging
any trees my point being if we could
condition that it would allow a little
bit easier access if cars are coming out
of the site whatever if if there is room
for a car to park in that area you see
the bits I mean underneath the
overhanging tree could we could we
condition that or could is that
something that we might put a note on
that officers working with the applicant
could try and improve that situation I
say that because obviously the parish
council and the the ward member are
asking for this and it seems to me to be
quite sensible I think when you look at
that image there what you see is that
there as you say these trees are
overhanging
but other than signage and some scrub
there is not a great deal in that area
which
technically be the visible disabilities
player you're talking about the
alterations further to that that anyone
could seek would be alterations to the
levels I think alterations to levels and
ground works in that area would be
harmful to the route protection areas of
those trees I know our culturalist
but I think that in normal planning
terms that is what you would likely
expect to happen in that situation it
would be harmful to the trees so the
answer's no I don't have information
before me that says there wouldn't be
harm to those trees if we went down that
route just just to answer that I'm just
checking the gender I can't see that
Highway Authority you've actually
requested a visibility spike condition
which are quite commonplace on these it
would be possible to require that and if
members were happy to delegate authority
to officers to come up with an
acceptable visibility space in
conjunction with the highways officers
excellent I'm just going to come to that
on the into in terms of the double
yellows as I understood it cancer which
is you're talking about both on the a3
400 and the access road the access road
is a fairly easy one to answer it's
private road so you couldn't put double
yellows on it because it's not a county
road the a3 400 you could but we haven't
asked the question of County so I
couldn't say either way whether it's
possible yes they would be bound by it
the question then would be how far would
you want it would you and how far how
far would you want the double yellows to
extend for instance so it could be
conditioned you could condition a scheme
to be submitted to and approved in
writing to flesh out the detail I'd
become
can securely how far back from the
junction there is it where the road
divides one going to the care home one
going on to the the farm because is it
wide enough for two vehicles up to that
point of the division so there is a
divide in that location there there's a
passing place here at the turn into the
care home but there is an existing what
concerns me what concerns me is tailback
if any of more than two or three
vehicles turn off to go to the care home
or to the farm they on the farm land
beyond sorry what's the question is it
wide enough for two vehicles of vehicles
to pass either way from the junction to
the turning into the care home there's
room at the very start of the access but
then it tapers off such that it isn't
hence the requirement for a turning Bay
sorry passing by so could it be widened
that Bank taken down to make it wider
further back it could be but I'd go back
to my point about the TP OS that would
need to be taken into account and
officers haven't assessed it I think in
truth it is wide enough for two cars to
pass the concern from the Parish Council
is that it's not a lot wide enough for
two large vehicles to pass cancer but
before we go to discussion we agreed on
what we feel
are you asking questions well big person
but the question really was canceled
Lord and others have put forward
suggestions part of the discussion is
before we go for wood we need to know I
think it's part of the discussion that's
a debate we can raise that intubate Town
Council
okay any other technical questions right
move it open to debate them counts a
carriage first then council law in
council journals well thank you for
looking at this side for once right okay
that's a great photo to have up here for
me it's not it it's not about the
entrance it's about the Greenbelt and I
think we there are a lot of reasons
people want to see this side developed
you know for listed building reasons
probably more than anything else and I
think we have been perhaps too
accommodating to it to allow this and
overlook to the degree that the
Greenbelt issues now it's we're knocking
down the the red brick building right
which is ugly and everyone is very happy
about that
that's a planning game and so what
happens next one of those buildings I
like the design I think you know they're
they're modern but they they kind of
hang off the existing design so yes one
even two of those new modern ExtraCare
buildings
I can see compensating for for getting
rid of that that red brick building a
third I think is is asking a bit much
and then an entire 64 bed care home on
top of that is is a lot so when we come
to volume it is a massive increase in
volume
compared to what is there at the moment
so the definition impact on the openness
of the Greenbelt is is bound it's bound
to be there and that's that's what we
make our judgment on you know that's why
I'm saying I think we've been a little
too giving on this and and not looked at
our policy and what it says and why it's
their impact on the openness of the
green belt okay is it or isn't it I
think it's quite clear that it is right
we're saying it isn't but I so I
disagree with the officers on this one I
think there is an impact on the openness
of the green belt in which case we need
some very special circumstances none
have been given as far as I can see so I
would I would definitely propose we we
go against the officers in this and and
and go for refused if the discussion
comes - well there are very special
circumstances
there's the college finances alright I
think that's one of the reasons we're
bending over backwards on this fair
enough but there are other developments
that could finance the college there's
the listed building absolutely yes
getting rid of that red building having
some well-designed buildings next to it
but even when you look at the listed
buildings that our heritage expert is
saying you know we may just about very
much ameliorated is about strong as
he'll go so that the harm to the listed
buildings bye-bye all this new
development can be ameliorated but it
but it can't be forgotten because it is
there you might look at employment but
frankly there's a lot of care homes and
another care facilities that are that
are greatly struggling to find enough
workers as it is you look at the
provision of extra care for the for the
district yes we want extra care in the
strips but we want affordable extra care
as well there's no affordable extra care
here at all you look at care home
provision well I'm told there's a market
catchment area needs hundreds of of care
home places but when I look at the the
works at County Council's market
position statement which which lays out
what we need in Stratford
I don't think across the whole district
we're looking for sixty-four new places
so so to have them all here with no
mention of affordability at all III
don't see that as a very special
circumstance so I'm in there and let
somebody else go on but I certainly
can't support this thank you chair yeah
it is difficult there is you know quite
considerable increase in accommodation
on the extant position but I am aware
that there is an extant permission I'm
not convinced that this is over
developments in the in the green belt I
think possibly it does have to be this
size to be sustainable as a business
opportunity and my concerns really are
with the with with the road access I
mean I am happy to go along with the
officer and I'm happy to propose
chairman that we grant planning consent
for this this application but I would
want to condition it and I'd want to
condition it really in accordance with
what we have on the update sheet and
those are the conditions from auric
County Council and that is that this
will not be developed until there is a
pedestrian crossing point which I
believe should be a pelican the
development shouldn't be occupied until
the vehicle access has been remodeled to
provide a pedestrian access and I would
also go with the third one you should
not be occupied in the development until
there's parking for the loading and
unloading of vehicles I would go with
the fourth condition if possible that I
would want to condition that a box
junction would be incorporated and
although it's not a condition those have
not before and I would also like a note
that the officers and the ward member
are both involved with the applicant in
doing whatever they can to upgrade the
access road where possible including
perhaps the widening of the Bell math
Junction I know that's a bit of a
mouthful but I'm sure that the planning
officer could help so that would be my
proposal if I can find a seconder hold
on a second before we go into - into
that we already have a proposal and we
need to go through that particular
process birth council Jones
I think the planning history of this
fight is really relevant because this
committee approved outline in November
2017 which is not a very long time ago
when one is considering the significance
scale of this site in the green belt and
actually that a bit it was an outline
proposal envisaged of a very much
smaller and much more modest scheme now
I entirely accept what the applicant
says which is this application reflects
the commercial realities however I
haven't actually seen evidence that the
commercial reality means that a site to
this scale okay it might need to be
bigger than that which was envisaged in
the outline but a site - this scale is
necessary and the reason that is so
relevant is because what about me
because what our heritage officer says
and I do turn committee members
attention to his comments on page 13
because this is actually a really
significant matter in the in the
planning balance that members have got
to think about and what he says is you
I'd say it's grudging acceptance of the
buildings to the west frankly and I I
agree with councillor courage you know
it is that or even those buildings too
much but there is an acceptance that
there is a degree of design in those
which is acceptable not as much concern
about those whoever the heritage
consultants
about that blacks like on the map the
green block there is really really clear
my opinion is that the volume of the
proposed new build would have the effect
of removing the current clear dominance
of Arden house as the major building on
the site it would be dwarfed in terms of
overall volume of built form it is
acknowledged that this negative impact
applies more to volume than to
significant visual diminution in the
dominance of Arden house there is in my
opinion clear and demonstrable harm to
the significance of the great - listed
building that represents less than
substantial harm which we know means
substantial harm is demolition so lessen
substantial harm is extremely
significant so and goes on to say the
location footprint and volume of the
additional proposed new broad element to
the north are the factors which lead to
my assessment of harm to the setting of
Arden house so the committee has to be
satisfied that that level of harm to a
listed building which we have a duty to
put a significant weight on is justified
now obviously there are justifications
because of the positive benefits of care
home provision but clearly a more modest
application for care home provision
would provide those benefits without the
harm and what I haven't seen is evidence
to my satisfaction that either this
level of density is necessary to make it
commercially viable to justify that
level of harm and secondly actually if
this level of density is required what
other proposals and iterations have been
considered specifically to address this
heritage consultants opinion because to
me actually we've been told well there's
been minor tweaks in terms of
landscaping on that east east side of
the north building but actually and
we're told it's felt to be the best
place because of car parking I haven't
heard a clear and robust answer about
why that footprint has to look like that
is it not possible to slightly reduce it
in size can we not move it slightly over
to the west can we change the angles of
it so that we can preserve Arden house
as as the listed building and the
dominant feature within that site
so for me that weighs very significantly
in the planning ballots and I don't feel
I'm afraid that the officers report has
sufficiently convinced me that the
factors in favor of this scheme outweigh
that that opinion is only strengthened
by the other factors I agree entirely
with councillor courage that I don't see
this has been case of very special
circumstances because it falls into an
exceptional agree about so it's it's an
it's brownfield land which allows us to
build however that doesn't mean impact
on the Greenbelt and the openness is a
green boat isn't a relevant planning
consideration and I'm happy to be
corrected if I've got that wrong but I
agree I do think this has an impact on
the openness as a green boat and when we
granted this in outline it was with
something much much more modest in mind
so what I've said about the density and
the volume what I've said about the
density and the volume and the impact on
our dam house because we can see then
that it's completely set to the side
there isn't that dominant I think that
applies to the green boat issues as well
so I think there are two reasons there
and then we've got this issue about
access now to me when committee is
straining to add so many hypothetical
conditions to an access it shows they're
not satisfied the the point is access is
a crucial part of a scheme and I know
we've got highway saying well we think
it's just about acceptable
we have information that's been provided
today that neither the parish have had
properly or all residents have had
proper chance to consider we have
concerns about the visibility display
and the widened access at the front with
a condition wanting to be placed on it
that it can be widened well I think we
have a duty as committee to have a look
actually whether widening is possible if
it's not does the access is it
acceptable in all the planning balance
not say well hopefully it will be and if
not well shrug again double yellow lines
may well be important mitigation but we
don't actually know whether that's
something that County think is
acceptable
could well come back and say actually it
may have this negative impact in
consequence and we don't agree with it
we don't think it's a reasonable
condition it appears to me that there
needs to be better discussion about
large vehicle passage particularly
because this is a care home commercial
deliveries ambulance and it seems to me
before an application comes on we should
have an agreed solution about whether
box Junction will keep clear is the best
solution and that should be a solution
which does have proper discussion
between relevant parties so to me when
you have to put so many caveats on the
access point is demonstrative the
committee aren't satisfied that accesses
is appropriate so I'm a second refusal
and I would prefer I would suggest that
the reasons our impact on the openness
in the Greenbelt the impact on the grade
2 listed building in accordance with the
heritage consultants opinion and lack of
satisfaction about a number of access
issues including visibility splay
conflict on the road double yellow lines
and parking box salute boxing and keep
clear solutions switches if you can
remember what you're gonna say following
that whilst coach Joseph Ecklie very
eloquently explained the concerns and
harm that could be and very much we
haven't looked in the final paragraph of
the heritage consultants report which
does go on to say that if we can as part
of them the dissemination of the
applicator application secure the future
of Arden house most most obviously by
attaching conditions is outlined then
the hum identified to the hardened house
is a consequence of the adverse impact
on a setting would very much be
ameliorated so therefore the
considerations have been have been
weighed and actually the harm has been
outweighed in in that planning process
so whilst those issues are very much
real they have been outweighed in the
planning process in in the heritage
consultants consideration not just our
officers consideration so I'm
comfortable with that to the green belt
issue again I think the officer has
outlined
reasons why in green belt terms this is
acceptable and that is that we are
losing a demonstrable amount of
buildings that are already on site and
replacing them with another set of
building so actually the the openness is
being preserved because some buildings
to come down to and being replaced by
others what don't think that is a valid
argument I still do have issued over the
access but with the conditions have been
outlined by councillor Lawton in
addition I'd like to add and I would
request that he includes these in his
proposal if that's okay the double
yellows and as we agreed or discussed
during the technical questions I would
be happy to second that proposal thank
you interesting points raised by by both
sides of the argument on here
one thing that I'm actually quite
conscious of is that very little
opposition has been raised to the scheme
itself yes the access is a problem and I
agree with counsel Richards on that
particular point but as has been said in
principle they are happy with the scheme
and that's been said a couple of times
so I don't feel that the arguments
against the openness and suchlike are
valid in this particularly as I do think
the officers got those correct where I
support council Richards is the access
on the on the road the junction in
particular and obviously council Norton
as well and also perhaps the widening of
it and that's one of our concerns I do
have about this particular scheme so I
go with cancer Richards on this
particular point so you wanted a race
yes I'm sorry you've actually go a
little bit about the displays and what
have you I forgot to say because ha
struck a concentrate somewhat councillor
Jalla said the displays you said there's
I think Richard you said that there was
no requirement for a splay drawing again
I sort of I've whispered that's council
law and he's agreed that I think we
should have that so it clearly
demonstrates the appropriate splay and
if it's not there that they have to be
met galavant
yes we're in a difficult situation we've
been in this situation with Highways
before we haven't agreed with them I
think once we deferred the application
its deadly for a little time to get it
right which did actually work the other
thing in my concern is I have been had
two of these applications at different
places over the last few years and I
think cancer Java remember it has to be
in a sustainable location now the one
that the make bird center they said we
could have it at a pelican crossing as
far as I'm concerned I appreciate this
is an open country sighs I'm just
wondering how they're going to get to
the doctors the other application we've
had that's been a substantial thing now
if they're going to have to walk down
the road or walk across the road the
highways have got to do something so I
have to go along with the offices
recommendation in that respect but we've
got to get something done with his
Highway because it's not a sustainable
location just coach well I guess I just
say I absolutely take care of Jars
suggestions for that for my proposal
file proposal the three reasons of
Greenbelt and effect on the listed
building or heritage aspects which were
talked about because I don't believe the
words very much ameliorated mean
surpassed that those are the word to use
is the heritage officer yeah we're in
semantics but in my opinion they're not
so for the three reasons I think we
should go to the vote I think we've all
had a had a word on it okay sorry check
on the on the highways reason if I can
just point out to members that there is
an extent consent that the council has
granted this application with
would have less traffic movements than
the concern that the council granted
can we turn that into a note or
something can I just cover so are you
saying basically the all this debate
about the access has been completely
irrelevant because we've already granted
the access in a in a appeal situation
the fact that the council has granted
planning permission for a scheme that
has more highways impact than a schema
is now refusing for highways reasons
probably wouldn't stand up one of the
rate one of the reasons is highway
and yes sorry just a second before they
carry on with what Ross was just saying
there are you saying therefore that the
conditions that we were proposing for
example the other lines the pocket
unction etc would not be reasonable and
therefore no no I was simply referring
to the proposed reasons for refusal and
saying that the third one the highways
one I have concerns with can I come back
to it because it did it doesn't make if
you if we have concerns over that
why don't we have concerns over the
other suggestion I think what she's
trying to say is if you had that as a
reason for future you've got to be sure
that you couldn't have conditioned it
and as we've heard there's the
possibility of putting type certain
conditions on to make it acceptable
you should only refuse permission if you
couldn't make it acceptable through
conditions previously for instance the
development up-up me on her visit as
Stratford on the right we we refused
that because there weren't sufficient
details and information about the
proposed Junction for that I mean and I
think that was my point you know with
research you know and all sorts of
different ways to try and make this
Junction acceptable but it's very much
hypothetical and we have no idea where
we're going with it
so you know just to say it needs more
work I think the point is that we as a
council and I believe as a committee
have already granted permission for that
junction in a previous application that
will have more traffic movements or as
supposedly I have more traffic movements
so why had been refusing on the basis of
that Junction isn't sufficient given
we've already agreed that it is for a
different more traffic intensive
development is the point now I'm
satisfied that the the conditions that
Castle Lawton and I have put forward
before the junction itself are
sufficient to cover any concerns that we
have
Road is a different math correct again
I'm very happy to stay with that third
reason actually because I think it was
it was a very different application the
last one last year I know the applicant
has said maybe there'll be less traffic
but it was a much much smaller
application frankly so I know it's a
slightly different news class but not
much I think the traffic will be
different and more on this one and I
think all right I'm getting an idea
stand okay fine I think we've had an odd
number into discussion and debate on
this particular point we do have a
proposer we do have a seconder on this
item we have got the conditions would
you like to just go over those please
before we go to a vote sorry the the
condition just for the refused all yet
the reasons for review so on the basis
of the refusal the reasons that I've
gathered from committee are there is one
most members except that it's a
brownfield site nonetheless the scale of
development would adversely impact on
the openness of the Greenbelt even
having regard to the existing buildings
on the site that would be the first one
details of these to be worked the actual
wording with you Chairman second one
would be harm to the grade 2 listed
building in terms of diminishing its
status on site and the level of that
harm would be in the less than
substantial category and not outweighed
by any public's benefits
okay and was it just those two were you
asking me for comment on access okay as
has been said before I think it would be
very difficult to de piel to justify
that but nonetheless good luck from what
I can gather from members what you're
saying is the increase in traffic
generation as a result of the proposals
would increase decrease the levels of
highway safety at the access which is
already an area subject to queuing and
would cause awkward turning move
movements and poor visibility exists at
such times is that really what was yeah
I think it's the cumulative impact of a
number of highways concerns including
visibility at the junction turning
movements impact on queueing traffic and
conflict within within the access road
yeah okay I understand the point of
visibility but as we have advice that
could be conditioned if necessary
several of those points could be
conditioned should we take it out yeah
yeah they're just the first two
remembers we have a vote to refuse
planning permission for 17 such oh three
206 subs for all those in favor to
chairman
against the proposal fails we do have a
proposal from Council Norton we do not
just go over the conditions that we were
suggesting on that particular point
please counselor if you'd like me to
German yes let me just get my notes
sorry yes that we we go with the
officers recommendation to grant consent
and the conditions I'd like to see on it
with council Richards are the the three
conditions on the update sheet as noted
plus the condition that the Box Junction
will be incorporated and we would also
like to see a provision of double yellow
lines and the widening of the bell mouth
whether that is a conditional whether
that is something we could put as a note
that the officers will work with the
applicant comment on that yeah I think
it's the working up of the of the birth
of the scheme including the displays is
ultimately what it was and that I
believe could be conditioned from the
response I got from one I would like to
obviously if that that is acceptable
then I would suggest that it comes to
both myself and the board member just
just on the double yellow lines Richard
I don't know if you've got any on this
but I think without having the county's
Council's input on that and whether
that's even feasible I'm not sure we can
secure it by condition I was gonna
suggest because it was mentioned whether
they should be conditions on that that
was one I would suggest being a note
that officers work with the county to
see if that's feasible and then perhaps
report back to you I'm happy with that
chair yes
are we still conditioning these plays
demonstration displays yeah shall I go
through the wording for that I've got so
let's start with the visibility space so
that would be before the development
hereby permitted is commenced a scheme
for the provision of acceptable
visibility space your base mister to
improved in writing that would be that
condition would you want that to go
through you or you yeah okay and then
the next condition would be now just
need to clarify this point because
initially in the discussion it was a
keep clear area as per the highway
comments but recent comments it's become
a box Junction can I just clarify it's a
box
it's a box junction okay in that case
then the condition would be a scheme for
the provision of a box junk of box
Junction markings at the site access
with the a3 400 to be submitted to him
writing could you answer that the scheme
for box Junction and any associate the
wo lines as required or as necessary yes
yeah it makes sense to come yeah not
does that way so I've actually got two
additional conditions to the update in
addition to the three on the update
sheet thank you members happy with those
conditions right there for members the
vote before use the granted planning
permission for 17/3 206 of all weather
conditions that we've just mentioned all
those in favor against this committee
therefore resolves to grant plan
permission for 1703 206 at all thank you
I'm gonna take a short break now
five-minute break thank you
thank you everybody well I guess move on
really agenda and that one took a little
longer than I think most people have may
have anticipated right the next item on
the agenda is 17 such oh three six four
nine so four which is land rear of
bramble Bank of da claim Alfred and
David is our presenting officer Thank
You chairman so the application site is
denoted by the black dot in the center
of the slide it's within the north
eastern area of the village of wealth
Adan even and here we have a slide
showing the site which is outlined in
red this or pinky purple lines here
denote the conservation area and the
dotted green line here is a public
right-of-way that skirts along the
northern boundary of the site actually
forms part of the Aven valley way and is
an aerial photo of the site so you can
see that tree line boundaries it's very
open there's no existing buildings of
significant note
this slide shows an extract from the now
made as in adopted Welford neighborhood
development plan the black line which
I'm just highlighting here shows the
formal built-up area boundary that's
been established through the
neighborhood development plan and then
the pinkie shaded area here is the
application site which sits almost
entirely outside of the built-up area
boundary here are some existing site
photos this is the area where the actual
house will be built some other angles of
the site looking towards the north top
one bottom one looking sort of Northwest
this is the proposed site layout so we
have the proposed dwelling in the center
the site here surrounded by quite a
large plot which would be landscaped and
[Applause]
the purple area proposed here is
proposed to be used as an area of public
open space these are some photos of the
area that is forming part of the
proposal is public open space you can
see that it's rather wild I suppose it's
just you described it as scrubland at
the moment and just see the part fair to
the side of the land it's a slightly
more zoomed in version of the proposed
site layout concentrating on the house
and you see it's quite a large plot
split into several areas not sure if you
can make out the word day but that says
lon and then just down here we've got
meadow so the scheme involves quite a
lot of planting landscaping on the the
curtilage surrounding the dwelling which
would sit centrally the site access
leads off duck Lane
through an area of existing I suppose
tree and scrub planting to an area of
hard surfacing just improve the dwelling
and this is some photos of the proposed
access location along duck lane there is
an existing field gate already in place
it doesn't appear to be new for a number
of years but it is there and there's
some of the adjacent accesses the top
photo actually shows where the Avon
Valley Way meets meets duck lane
follows the line of a shared driveway
partially before entering into the open
countryside the bottom photograph shows
probably the only existing building on
the site which is in close proximity to
duck Blaine I'm assuming it was some
form of garage at some point storage
building and here we're moving on to the
elevations of the proposed dwelling so
we can see it's a very modern
contemporary design featuring a number
of different materials quite a lot of
natural materials we've got a sedum roof
green wall there some horizontal
brickwork timber cladding on the bottom
photographs showing the southern
elevation is mostly glazed actually with
sliding timber screens at first first
floor level and here at the east and
west elevations so you can see here that
there are slight height differences in
the design flat roof to the highest
point is 6.5 meters from the adjacent
ground level moving on to the floor
space here this is the ground floor so
quite a large open-plan living area and
hallway and then this wing here as a
playroom gym storage garage first floor
you can see the sedum roof here the
green roof there's an external balcony
area and then
living space comprising seven bedrooms
and bathrooms on Suites
in total the dwelling would create
somewhere in the region of 595 square
meters of new residential floor space
and I have a video of the site if anyone
members feel that will be useful this is
panning from the Aven valley way
looking east cross through the sites we
can see this is the site of the house so
it's very open very rural in character
at the moment and then facing towards
the east actually looking down the line
of the Hayden Valley way towards the
area of land that would be proposed to
be public open space and that's the end
of the presentation
there are updates in the update sheet
including several less support that have
been received recently and a correction
to the officer report and the
recommendation is to refuse planning
permission for the reasons detailed in
the officers recommendation it's it's
been put forward by the applicant as
part of the scheme it's likely to be
something we we may want to talk about a
bit later really at this stage it
wouldn't be something due to the scale
of the development for one dwelling the
officers feel we could secure through
either a section 106 or possibly even
reasonably through a planning condition
it's essentially an offer by the
applicant as as I understand it okay
thank you
right first speaker is a mr. Phil right
Bobby right and Jane casual
when you're ready have three minutes in
your own time
thank you so hi I'm Phil this for my
wife Bobbi
we're not developers this is an
application for our own personal hogs
we've got five children
we've lived currently in the same house
in Welford for the last 16 years so this
isn't something that we do on a regular
basis at all this building we believe is
one of exception of design and does make
a positive contribution to the
surrounding area this is this appears to
be the main significant and fundamental
point of the application the officer has
been using power 55 to inform his
decision however we don't think that
it's just informing it we think it's
being used as a strict benchmark to
assess this planning application our
application meets policy a is 10 of the
core strategy and policy any five of the
neighbourhood plan which quite simply
says that buildings of exceptional
design can be proved outside the BAU be
there's no qualification at all on how
exceptional designed is to be judged in
in that and specifically there's no
requirement to use or reference power 55
we've taken legal counsel on this as
well and the barrister unambiguously
concluded the case officer is wrong in
using power 55 to assess his application
so that leaves you with trying to decide
how to judge what is exceptional design
hopefully you'll agree that qualified
architects are probably the best people
to assess design and merits of a
building and this is exactly what the
Planning Department do when they use
made and they refer planning decisions
and decisions to made with that in mind
we approach six regional chairman and
chair women of RIBA councils to
independently assess the project one of
them sits on the equivalent of maiden
size and two of whom are lecturers in
design quality all although we concluded
separately that this application is
exceptional design it sits well within
its surroundings and it makes a positive
contribution to the area they are also
suggesting that it's potentially
award-winning it's an award-winning
project that's the main point but there
are also a few other additional points
that we'd like to get noted both
community supports this application
there's 30 letters of
port for this application and three
letters of objection this is pretty much
unheard of in Welford in addition to
this by far the majority of residents
that neighbor the the actual application
have written in with letters of support
and none of them have objected to it
Wellford primary school awfully also
formally support this application in
addition to that the the community
benefits from the application
approximately a third of an acre is goat
is going to be given to Welford school
to create a forest school approximately
third of an acre is thirty second
springs we've been given to the parish
to create much-needed open space and the
eighth and final way is going to be
widened and improved and then finally
just like I say that site itself is
going to benefit as well so post build
the site has a biodiversity gain it'll
improve the visual look and feel and
pota build a large area of land will be
protected and given over to managed wild
meadow thank you sir any questions you'd
like to raise just one particular point
on exceptional time it is subjective of
course it is but houses where this
design come from has it been something
you've evolved or was it we we we saw
ages ago a designer called Marty Logan
who's a Brazilian architect too as
dissin fantastic designs really really
organic really in keeping with the
environments and we then briefed a
British architect practice called
Nicolas tie to to do something that's in
accordance with that sort of style so
it's it's a design of air briefing and
our making but designed to try and be
really organic and fit in within the
wildlife an environment that it's in
that's rigid given the type and style of
housing in Welford can you explain to me
why you think this fits in with that
style and how it may complement that
style yeah I mean I thought I I mean I
think it the classic counterpoint is as
a village well that has got well if it's
got loads and loads of different style
house
and in decline and in particular in
decline there's many different sorts of
houses and those houses that are taller
than this one houses a bigger in volume
than this one and this house is a foot
set further back than this one from
Dublin and there's lots of different
style houses but importantly I think
it's it moves away from the sort of
standard fairly bland designs that are
often made at the moment where they're
just classic ordinary modern houses
we've tried to create a building that
sits comfortably within its environment
by being quite organic and natural it's
look how's the building can we go back
to the site plan between your property
and the houses to the south of it is
that just open fields or they playground
what is what is that man
he's re-wet whereabouts between your
house and the houses to the south which
is all part of the bu ba what is that
land is it just open fields or is it
playgrounds what is it
whereabouts you mean immediately below
that an area between the pink object and
that's I think the book that is owned by
family called the strands and it's not
farming he's up the back of that house
which is Manor
I think it's manifold okay any other
questions members okay thank you very
much thank you
council Barnes
now I remember to max and that then you
come along with max you see um yes mr.
chairman
last week at least we had three houses
which were outside the village boundary
which a good design which actually was
against was opera butyl and actually we
unanimously approved this is just out of
the village boundary one has to accept
that if you could put the picture on
that half before that would be
appreciated the red one that the point
being is this this couple have got five
children I did see them when they had
four children trying to get through by
the church coming to the school we were
shorter children about Dominus to teach
at school so we were very pleased and
they have helped immensely with the
school and their parents have worked in
The Parent Association done a lot for
the school in the village so it isn't
something that's just sort of arrived
they've been looking at this site and we
agreed that if it was sympathetic or the
way it is we would look at it if you
look at the site whether the red line
comes from the side from the right hand
side there is a seven-bedroom house
there that we voted for small houses we
lost and the district council came up
with his suggestion of six bedrooms and
it's it kids a colossal great house it's
got an extra bedroom on for the simple
reason is for the bats so I know that
sounds a bit silly but it is in keeping
with the area it is out of the boundary
and as the gentleman said my village and
many villages have different sorts of
buildings they're built at different
times we have two if you like eco house
in the village which have were opposed
by the parish council this isn't being
opposed by the parish council if you
look there where you see the green
houses on that that was an application
outside the village bounty for five
houses some weeks ago came to you
refused that that went straight through
an appeal as far as the the inspector
was it agreed it's just outside the
village boundary but it was as far as he
was concerned sustainable to the area
the other thing is that as you can see
it's on the Aven way the urban way is
from Stratford to airship there is one
place to cease
that's a Biddeford a lot of people try
and get in Western Church have they've
gone sort of followed miles and can't
these this proposal is to include a
piece for the school which the head is
very pleased on wildlife and birds and
also an accessible place on the ovum way
in a rural setting for people to sit and
have a rest
there isn't any other place on the only
way to stop and I think it will be
agreed and have been agreed by the
parish council you know that parish
council they've always opposed
everything but they're not actually
opposed in this because they can see the
benefits far as I'm concerned I fully
support this application have to have a
few amendments have moved it from the
weather even Wavell back I did there is
a house opposite in the field opposite
although it doesn't show on the
right-hand side you then got the river
on the top there that's where the river
is though it's just off the floodplain a
world meadow could be included in the
back which is part of the proposal and
as they say this family having just
arrived in the village they bred in the
village they've got the last child I
think he's about to leave the
with school this year if you understand
the fauna children have been to the
school so what I'm saying is far as I'm
concerned with support from everybody in
the area everybody there you can see by
the green eyes is all the way to the
side he's fully supportive and I hope
that you will look at it objectively and
approve it if you answer any questions
on this I'm sure
thank you very much the first thing I
appreciate that the person account Town
Council aren't here to comment on this
they are here but they haven't
registered to speak both yeah well the
thing is that they have raised it as an
objection and page 50 considers our
proposed running is not exceptional
quality and design so it cannot be
supported outside the village area
Landry you've been on the chair long
enough to know that the parish can so if
they're concerned about something come
and speak Catalan did you want to point
well it was that point actually only
does the north rejection here which is
which is pertinent but it is a rejection
that has a caveat and the question
really I've got to if you don't mind
council answer the first one is that the
parish council the same they would
withdraw an objection if a professional
planner has supported the the design or
Godsey got one professional planner here
who doesn't but that's one point my
point was that there is there is some
planning game here which is this strip
of land which is being off the desert as
an open space it is we need scrubland at
the moment it's it's not usable do you
know if the the parish has funds to
clear this error up if if it is gifted
to gift it to the parish or because it
looks like if without a little bit of
money spending on it it's not going to
be much use
the school has funds to do the school
part which is the end part there and
then the other part obviously yeah would
be up to the parish council to there is
under the new system
the reason those five houses there that
will be coming through so there will be
money from development to be able to
doose's I don't think personally opening
and improving the space will cost a lot
of money but there will be a certain
amount of money for council with your
knowledge of that I mean that there is a
amount of calculated cio there it's over
forty thousand pounds which is not
insubstantial
it is you saying that the parish council
earmarking that SIL or the proportion of
the SIL they get because they'll get 25
well I'm suggesting is it very close
through that area there will be some
money available to the fairy castle
I suggest that was a technical question
we can ask them to counter character you
mentioned an appeal is that an appeal on
the green house yes on the right yes
okay thanks that the inspector came on
Friday one lady was actually delivering
leaflets against an application in
Dublin and it was literally fit and
within six days he'd come to his
agreement that it went through as a
suitable size in fact he said most of
the out of the area in the village off
the floodplain is actually sits in a
sustainable location thank you cancer
right technical questions you very much
to ask that same one again but there is
a calculation here of 44 odd thousand is
am i right in assuming that 25% of that
money would go to the parish council to
spend as they wished or is it the whole
amount and I'd be like well rich is for
innovation grants this actually any
parish councils that's got a
neighborhood development plan which made
gets 25% of the silver seal it's 25
percent to 44 right it worries the 44
already 25% to a larger sum was my
question no bigger the calculation of
the 44 in the officer report is what
would be generated from this this site
okay so 11,000 pounds I could
although members should note with sill
that there are exemptions so there's no
guarantee that this particular
development would pay SIL although the
council would have the parish council
would have funds generally from
development in the village I think it's
those self-abuse in self gold is exempt
themselves yeah okay council carry to do
yes it's interesting I'm self built
wasn't it bit under okay
yeah the appeal um I hadn't heard the
opilio haven't seen the appeal case it
seems quite relevant to this i remember
that coming to this committee and
turning it down I remember is turning
him down on on on the fact that it would
reduce the distance between two
different communities but it sounds like
there has been some comment by an
inspector on its proximity to the
built-up area boundary so can you
enlighten me on that the with regards to
orchard nurseries the inspector actually
found based on evidence provided by the
applicant on that site that the use of
the site was not agricultural it was
actually a storage and distribution use
he found that the plants were being
stored there before being moved
somewhere else over there from a
brownfield site where and the planning
policies in the NDP and in the core
strategy aren't necessarily against
redevelopment of a brownfield site so it
was the only mention of the built-up
area boundary in that position I think
there was there was some brief mention
of it with regards to it being not an
isolated site but my reading if that
Appeal decision was that more weight was
put on fact it was a brownfield site and
as well as things are improvement of the
design character plan landscape views
things like that that's good thank you
cata fielding I voted in favor of the in
the greenhouse area but I'm concerned
that this development will create an
area that could be become infill between
it and the the houses on to the south
if we granted is that could that be the
case it's difficult to speculate on that
because we judge every application on
its merits so further planning
applications would have to be made if it
was the intention of developers to
develop this land
I think there's access restrictions
there with regards to bringing in access
into this land so it could be difficult
and I don't particularly think if this
this application was granted or members
thought they support an approval that it
would set a precedent that that's my
view in with regards to how we interpret
the policies that kept the area if I
could just add to that it's not unusual
for some built parry boundaries to be
drawn with the hole in them so if this
was granted and then a future built
barrier boundary were to be drawn that
could be a hole where those fields is
thank you okay well Sweden even has
spent a lot of time putting together a
neighborhood development plan which
constructs a built-up area boundary what
honestly is the point of any of that if
you just say shrug and unless there's a
clearly demonstrated exception to it so
we have to be satisfied that there's a
clearly demonstrated exception and
actually in my view this is an extremely
thorough detailed and well reasoned
report about actually why that exception
doesn't exist and what the purpose of
that bill tu'pari boundary is and I
think the most significant parts of the
report are page 52 and it took the
report talks about the defined built
area boundary and actually the purpose
of that and then it goes on at page 54
to talk about if you're going to allow
which has got to be exceptional desire
and I completely agree with what the
officer is said which is actually in my
view the proposed dwelling does not it
doesn't offer it particularly
exceptional innovation it's not
exceptional
our materials proposed do not surpass
current and increasingly common
architectural standards or introduced
new ideas or techniques that can be
considered to be exceptional having
regard to the examples of modern
architecture elsewhere so you know it's
not just all this looks a bit different
to other houses nearby therefore it's
exceptional it's it's got to show some
particular architectural merit and I
completely we've seen designs that look
like this that are essentially
contemporary modern to me that is a
contemporary and modern design I also
think important from the port is page 56
which talks about harm to the overall
pattern of development the scale in the
mass of the building is not considered
to be acceptable in the wider landscape
and the openness the purpose partly of
this built-up area boundary it's to
retain that sense of openness rockford
is a rural village it has a public
right-of-way and I think the idea that
it's a planning benefit to tidy up every
piece of rural land to make it manicured
neat accessible that's not why people
use public rights-of-way they use it to
experience something different you're
sitting your own back garden if you want
to experience manicured managed
pieces of land I think actually we need
to have in close proximity to villages
different types of land and that's the
purpose of this you have public open
space which is yes accessible and
there's plenty of Latin Walford but also
accessible nearby walks that provide
something that's a bit rougher a bit
more rural and we don't get tidying up
absolutely every single piece of land
I'm not actually particularly
comfortable with this idea of a
trade-off with the school well okay
we've got certain individuals that
support the application that looks at
things very much on certain individuals
in the here-and-now and the whole point
of the planning process is that we have
a consistency of approach and we look to
manage land not just about how it
benefits people in the very short term
but how it benefits communities in the
medium and long term
we managed land so for me there's
nothing in this report that to me
doesn't thoroughly support its
conclusions and for that reason I would
propose refusal thank you
if you want a neat manicured garden you
don't want to come into mind
unfortunately yeah I completely agree
with what money's just said it's also
worth remembering that it was a matter
of weeks ago two to three weeks ago we
refused a planning application in
Clifford for an a dwelling that was
outside the built-up area boundary if
for nothing else consistency sake we
should be but everything Mallya said is
absolutely valid I don't particularly
believe that this is a significantly
higher design than any other property
actually I think my personal opinion is
it detracts from some of the quality
buildings and historic buildings are in
Moffat or I will be supporting Thank You
chairman yeah I think I'm minded to
agree with with the last two speakers
are I'm not convinced that this building
is of such architectural merit that it
comes back I mean I I would say to the
applicants perhaps if they had supported
the parish council that might have
swayed my opinion but it's obviously not
fully there I mean if it came back with
an MA B design thing I think it would be
a grounds but it's not been demonstrated
here so I'm very happy with the officers
report and and I would go with it
Kelsea character well I've seen some of
those M ad e recommendations and we
could have a lovely multicolored octopus
there which they would approve of I'm
not quite sure I would I take your point
that it is what is now becoming
contemporary modern whatever you want
modern architecture for today I really
like it yeah I wouldn't like the the
applicant to sell what we need to do
about standard boring
you know house that
could be both his homes certainly not
great architecture I'm glad to see this
more and more and more coming forward to
this committee but not exceptional maybe
that's a good thing but it doesn't fit
our policy if it did we'd had parish
council support there might be different
thank you I do have sympathy with the
the applicants on this particular point
because obviously it they want to remain
in the village and they think they
brought up with an exceptional design I
do concur exactly I think that it's not
an exception we have seen similar
designs and it is outside of the build
up area boundary that has gone through a
due process with the the Neighborhood
Development Plan with this this parish
council and I know the pain and anguish
that takes to get to that stage so I to
have to support it now I do have a
proposer council Giles do I have a
seconder on this oh so I had I missed
that councillor metres members the vote
before you is to refuse planning
permission for 70s - Oh 364 knives for
all those in favor
thank you this committee therefore
resource to refuse planning permission
for 1703 six for 9/4 right Amy you're on
now last item on the agenda is 17 such a
35 for nice fish for the bath Paul head
Lane Tanith and Arden
Thank You chairman the application sites
donated by the black dot is within a
ribbon of development along Hall head
laying would end which has an eclectic
design mix of residential dwellings the
application site is William wood ends
draft bill turf area boundary would end
as a category for local service village
the situs of in the West Midlands
Greenbelt and Arden special special
landscape area the site edge red is west
west of Poole head lane and forms part
of the garden lanta path north of the
site residential dwellings bound to the
site the north east and south with
labret gulf course to the west full
planning permission is sought to
demolish the existing garage which
serves the bath and direct one dwelling
with associated works within the grounds
of the bath the site would utilize the
existing access which serves the bath
and the property would be set back
approximately 24 metres from Poole head
Lane a detached dwelling with twin gable
design set behind a single-story flat
roof garage is proposed the ridge height
would not exceed that of the bath and
would retract retain separation
distances of 3.5 meters between the
proposed dwelling and the bath and two
point three meters between Heather drift
residential property to the south the
dwelling would be constructed from Park
render cedar cladding and aluminium
windows and the floor plans are now
being shown which shows living space
over free floors so these images have
been taking looking west into the site
from Poole head Lane and you can see the
existing garage which is proposed to be
demolished it's a bit clearer in the
bottom photo and this image is taken
from within the site looking east
towards cool head lane and you can see
the relationship between the bath and
have a drift and this property on the
left hand side is the bath and and again
this image is taken from within the site
looking northeast towards the access at
Paul head lane and finally just some
images just to show and the character of
over residential dwellings a long pool
head pain and so chairman there is one
update on the update sheet and the
recommendation is to grant the
application subject to conditions as
detailed in the committee report thank
you thank you
our first speaker is counselor Carol
Shepperd Thank You counsel you have
three minutes in your own time good
evening I'm as you're aware parish can't
let time with parish council has
launched an objection to the proposed
infill dwelling adjacent to the baths in
Bullhead Lane on design grounds give him
the time I will keep this brief whilst
the Parish Council agrees of the officer
there's an eclectic mix of properties in
the road the orientation of the proposed
additional dwelling is Gables road
rather than eaves to Road as is the case
with the immediately neighboring
properties and they're in the majority
of properties in the lane
furthermore the only contemporary design
does not so tend to blend with the
adjacent properties and fails to use
when IKEA materials
indeed it features of a large amount of
glass and cedar cladding which is with
100 year old what and building with
which it will share an access and would
therefore have a detrimental impact on
the street scene surely the fact that
the properties will be linked by shared
access imposes a requirement for a giant
design which is more sympathetic and
bashful with the bath the main Congress
one which has been submitted in all of
the recent up of infill applications
designs have been in accordance with
local character in the interest of
maintaining high quality design which
fits the local character of the parish
the Parish Council asked for your
support in requesting the design of this
proposed property we amended to
something more in harmony with the bath
thank you for listening thank you very
to castor father any questions you would
like to
race and sorry did I pick up the ax
saying that the gables and the dormers
our doctor proposed in this particular
part okay I get that point Thanks
thank you very much sir all right our
next speaker is mrs. Taylor thank you
mr. Dale you have three minutes just
press the button at the very bottom of
the microphone and away you go
good evening everybody
and thanks for the opportunity to
address the committee tonight I just
really would like to say that we are
hoping to build this house for ourselves
and we want it to be fairly contemporary
about my quality and it would comply
with the latest environmental standards
our present her in the bath has been a
happy family home for over 20 years but
it's now too large and as 220 years old
expensive to upkeep for just myself and
my husband the officers have recommended
the application should be approved the
proposed new dwelling complies with all
relevant planning policies of the
adopted Stratford core strategy in
particular the policies allow for infill
development within local service
villages such as wood end
the site is clearly located within the
settlement boundaries and there should
be no question about the principle we
note the parish objection and have tried
to liaise with them directly on this
scheme prior to the committee
unfortunately we do not agree with their
concerns in respect of the proposed
design the local plan encourages
innovation and contemporary design and
my understanding is that there is no
policy issue or concern from the council
over the design of the dwelling the
character of pool head Lane is one of
many distinct style
styles and the proposal is not a
significant departure from this we have
liaised with the council on the proposal
from early pre-application discussions
which includes reference to the eclectic
style and gable design and committee
report confirms that Gables are a design
feature along pool head Lane it is
therefore unclear why the parish is
opposed to this attractive high-quality
proposal we have reduced the size of the
new dwelling enclosed discussion with
the council and it now exceeds the
council's minimum separation distances
it sits attractively within the plot and
there is no concern from overlooking any
adjacent dwellings it is set back from
Port Hedland by 24 metres and accessed
from the existing access serving the bar
the scheme is supported by councillor
George Atkinson he confirms our view
that the dwelling would be in keeping
with the generality of the architectural
pool had lain and with the benefits of
invitees supportive of the amended
scheme we did not receive any other
objections to the original or amended
scheme we spoke to our neighbors before
we submitted the application and they
confirmed that they are happy with the
principle of the build and the house
itself there are also no highway or
ecology objections to the proposal as we
engage them throughout the process in
summary I would like to reaffirm our
view that the design size form and
location of the proposed Wehling is
entirely in accordance with the local
plan so I would therefore request you to
support and approve the application
thank you for your time and just to
clarify that you did engage with the
parish council okay you did engage with
the parish council over the design well
we went to the parish council meeting we
had the countless Stratford council come
out with to explain what we possibly
could and couldn't do with the design
and development to start okay thank you
and was there any other questions you'd
like to raise yeah thank you very much
Kal's rackets
good evening chairman members and
officers I fully endorse what mrs.
Taylor has so adequately explained to
you we do know that in the NPP f it
encourages innovation in design and
whilst this is perhaps slightly
different it's not what I would describe
and in the parish councils comments of
contemporary I think that was possibly
more with the previous application than
with this and if you look at page 77 of
your application I know it doesn't give
you a full picture of the contrast of
design which exists on pool lately but I
think you can see from the skeleton of
the outlines that you have got a
complete mix I would tend to hazard a
guess that on boohead lane there is no
two houses which are alike it's got that
characteristic and certainly my judgment
here is what is proposed by the
applicants is very much in keeping with
pool in Lane one thing I think which is
quite helpful is that there is not one
objection by a resident now the
immediate neighbor has his name up there
councillor Dixon I think if there was an
issue then you would have a pretty quick
email about it to me it fits in well it
fits in with the principles of in
filling which incidentally the parish
council didn't agree with in their
earlier comments and it's fits in with
the entire location I see nothing wrong
with this I think it's a very good
application
I hope members will reflect that opinion
in your decision and support the
officers very reasoned and valid
recommending
to grant thank you Jeff Thank You
counselor are there any questions you'd
like to raise that cast about Kristin
thank you very much
all right I should move on to technical
questions council jars I wonder if you
could explain for the benefits of
numbskulls and that's me well I don't
quite actually understand what say the
Parish Council says the Gabel to Road
it's not used to Road can you just
explain that in terms that somebody like
me can understand um you know how it's
different and competes with other things
here and they probably the easiest way
to for me to explain it is by using the
image here of the bath so I think
obviously as you can see this proposed
design has Gables fronting on to the
road and which is similar to this part
of the bath and however this part of the
bath here the gable does not front on to
the road its side facing so then you get
a different view of the property then
when you look at it from the right so
hopefully that helps try to explain it
if it in visual terms whereas the front
entrance to the proposed property is it
that little doorway the front entrance
okay see a picture so the top image is
the main house and the proposed dwelling
will go and so the proposed dwelling
would sit on the left so it's probably
easier to show you this photo which is
at the rear looking towards bullhead
Lane may I just interject on that so the
gable of the existing carriage does face
the road correct
so the gay but yeah sorry
so the gable of the existing garage will
it will be it
look similar to what's proposed yeah
Casa fielding see you've got various
pictures of the street scene there's any
chance of sort of seeing what other
properties are looking like along there
okay thank you any other technical
questions members if not I shall open up
to debate council autumn council County
Thank You chair having listened to the
concerns of the parish council my only
comment was that this is as a long road
with a lot of mix of old and new
properties and even the old properties
we knew once so I've got no problem with
the design and I think that the officers
report is perfectly correct and I'm
happy to propose that we accept this
planning application the coaches listen
to the parish council actually did make
me think because I was pretty much in
favor of it going ahead however what I
think the concern which which which rang
in my mind was they're sort of a hundred
and twenty year old nature of the BAFF
is it that yeah the the big old house
yeah it's got a certain character and
then all of a sudden you've got this
modern thing next door to it I don't
think the cabling to me makes any
difference at all when you up and down
the road there are a lot Gables facing
you there are an incredible number of
all sorts of weird and wonderful designs
from tiny little bungalows to big great
big things so and that's where I'm
coming to rethink it back to my original
position that actually that the officers
have got this completely right if you
look to the left of this property this
is sort of a bungalow or or a small one
and a half building I think if you go
the other side there are some
interesting designs as well so I think
putting a modern design here is
absolutely after all fine
so our second house that's all right I
thought it was going in a different
direction I can't see the point of the
parish council and like you know there
is an eclectic design along the street
and I think you know I have no problem
with a contemporary nature of the design
absolutely fine that courage it's a
non-active frontage and it's not
attractive
and actually I would have been minded to
have a design that you know I know that
there will be a more active frontage so
I think on balance it will be an
improvement I would have been inclined
to be honest to do something that maybe
was a modern similar design but did seek
to replicate perhaps the structure so I
actually do take the point of the parish
do I think it is sufficiently harmful in
terms of design or all of sufficient
lack of quality to say no no I probably
don't and I thought I would probably
have done things a little bit
differently but I don't think it's at a
level to say refusal thank you I have a
proposal and a seconder for this mem
members so I members to vote before you
is to grant planning permission for 17
such a 3/5 for lifecycle all those in
favor this committee therefore resolved
to grant plane permission of 70 such oh
three five four nine such thoughts thank
you there is no more business this
evening I will close the meeting thank
you